[Music]
Clint Eastwood's newest film is creating
a big buzz defying all conventional
moviemaking NORs by using real-life
heroes to play themselves the movie
stars three Americans who stopped an
Isis terrorist attack on a train in
France in 2015
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
spoke with the stars of 15:17 - Paris
Jen's I want to talk about this
experience of course it made
international headlines
it threw you all into the world's
consciousness Alec you and your friends
are on this train they're sleeping but
you're awake what did you hear and what
made you take action and waking them
well I was just hanging out texting some
friends back home and like two hours
three hours into the trip I heard a
gunshot and breaking glass and I kind of
put my head because I wasn't sure if
that was what I had heard or not I
couldn't exactly define it at the time
and while I was thinking about that a
train employee ran kind of past us away
from the noise a full sprint and so that
and we all kind of looked back to see
was running from and there was a
shirtless man the neck k47
so behind the seats and I was like
Spencer go get him let's go and Spencer
you take off down the middle of this
train heedless that the guy has an ak-47
pointed at you what made you run at him
at that moment I mean honestly it was
just we just wanted to live his pure
survival and that kind of caught a
moment down the aisle where I saw him
maybe either Jam the gun or maybe the
safety was on all I knew is that he
hadn't started shooting it and so I
pretty much just saw it as a window of
opportunity like you know hey it's
either Now or Never
we're gonna we're gonna die either way
so might as well give it a shot and
that's what really sprung me out of my
seat
Anthony your two friends have military
training you do not yet you went after
them up the aisle as well yeah I think
my motivator was been being lifelong
friends of mine that it kind of shut
down my brain process and it was like
once they jumped in action I had to just
go help really at that point it was kind
of all in or nothing type of situation
Spencer you you grabbed this guy a
member of an Isis cell he's got an ak-47
that's not all he was packing apparently
yeah what happened when you when you
tackled when I tackled him I was trying
to grab the a gate from him a little bit
I was practicing jujitsu at the time so
I kind of just went straight to that and
I that we both stood up I put him in a
rear naked choke slam myself against the
window so he's on top of me at this
point and he pulls out a pistol that he
had just shot the market medallion with
and he tries to shoot me with that but
luckily there was no ammunition in it
and Alek runs up prized the pistol out
of his hands as soon as the the pistol
it gets gets out of his hand he grabs a
box cutter
and starts cutting the back of my neck
almost trying to slit my throat with it
and then comes across and slices my left
thumb to the bone severs my tendon and
nerve and I looked over her shoulder saw
the knife and him kind of flailing
around I screamed he's got a knife and I
kicked him off me and then we all kind
of punched him and kicked him for a
little bit and I mean the fight went on
from there - but unbelievable do you
believe that there was a divine hand in
all of this in the way these events
transpired if you add up all the odds of
us being in that time in place and all
the circumstances that put us there all
the circumstances that went towards us
surviving it I mean that's going to be
in the movie too but it's just to me as
to astronomical to be coincidence so as
if all this wasn't terrifying enough
Anthony you all decide we're going to
approach Clint Eastwood with our book
and our story he decides to do this film
and cast you all as yourselves this had
to be a little intimidating having never
acted before you didn't do theater you
didn't do never school play or anything
nothing so we thought when he picked up
the picture that would be good enough
like this is the mountaintop he wants to
do our story we
that was great and then three weeks
before we start shooting we thought we
were meeting the actors who were playing
ourselves and he's like you mind
reenacted things for us on camera and
we're like sure we'll show the actors
for accuracy and he's like he says it
again and then we're like mysteries with
what do you mean here like he kind of
sound like you're asking us to be in the
movie he's like sure why not I think you
guys should be boys should just do it
Alec we used to have a lot of time with
him on the set Clint Eastwood yeah well
you spend a lot of time with him on set
I mean he worked longer days and we did
and we spent a lot of time with him
outside of said just hanging out getting
getting food getting drinks we even
would work out with them from time to
time and that's one of my favorite
memories of him is Spencer and I were
kind of talking smack to each other
about how many dips we could do and then
Clint comes in he's like oh yeah that's
nothing when I was 75 I could do 25 tips
and so we're like alright let's see what
you got now keep in mind he's 87 right
he hops up on the dip bar and just
knocks out ten body weight that's just
like nothing what did you learn from him
he gave us a lot more gems and showed us
a lot more about the industry in the
process than he had to to make the
picture so it felt like he was really
invested in us and he really wants to
see us and do well so we all want to
continue to pursue acting for sure
you're gonna continue this defense
absolutely I feel like he blessed us
with a great opportunity and he like
Anthony was saying he kind of raised
this world a little bit and we kind of
want to see what else we can do with it
and what do you want people to take away
from this experience given that Isis has
proven itself but this is the kind of
attacks they plan on enacting on the
public from now on even though these two
are off duty servicemen at the time that
we are three ordinary guys in that
ordinary people are gonna watch the film
and we don't have anything special in
our s3 it's we were just put in an
extraordinary situation and we hope that
people take that theme from the movie
that if they find themselves in a
situation with a terrorist or maybe any
obstacle that facing in their life that
they have the ability
to do something extraordinary themselves
if they do it together
most definitely thank you guys thanks
for being thank you